قالت وزاره الصحه بغزه ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يواصل تشديد الحصار على مجمع
ناصر الطبي في خان يونس ويستهدف محيطه
بشكل مركز واضافت الوزاره ان الاحتلال يضع
حياه 300 من الكادر الطبي
و450 جريحا بالاضافه الى 100 الاف نازح في
مستشفى ناصر في دائره الخطر
المباشر دوره قال مدير مستشفى الجراحه
بمجمع ناصر الطبي ان المجمع ي تحديات
عديده في ظل الحصار ابرزها شح الوقود ونقص
الكوادر امام الاعداد الكبيره للمصابين
واضاف في مقابلته مع الجزيره ان قوات
الاحتلال تواصل قصف محيط المستشفى وحذر ان
مئات من افراد الطواقم الطبيه والمرضى
والاف من النازحين في ساحات المجمع
يواجهون مصيرا مجهولا في ظل استمرار
الحصار النقص الحاد في الوقود ما يتوفر
لدينا يكفي فقط لمده اربعه ايام فقط
وتتوقف الخدمه الطبيه في المجمع وخاصه في
اقسام العمليات والعنايات المركزه ويعرض
حياه المرضى والمصابين في المجمع للخطر
التحدي الاخر الذي يواجه مجمع عناصر الطبي
النقص الحاج في الكوادر الطبيه التخصصيه
وخاصه جراحه المخ والاعصاب جراحه الاوعيه
الدمويه وجراحه الصدر حيث يصل المجمع
الكثير من الحالات والتي تحتاج الى تدخلات
جراحيه ونقوم بتحويل بعض الحالات الى
المستشفى الميداني الاردني بمخاطره ومجازف
كون لا يوجد ممر امن للمستشفى الميداني
الاردني